perché sur sa colline depuis le xiième
siècle la basilique de vézelay est l'un
des joyaux de la région un monument à
part qui attire chaque année près d'un
million de visiteurs venus du monde
entier nous sommes arrêtés avaient gelé
sur notre route depuis l'angleterre
nous visitons j'avais vraiment envie de
voir la basilique de marie madeleine je
suis très attiré par tout plat
spiritualité qui se dégage de ces lieux
ça fait quatre ans que je viens ici et
si je reviens souvent c'est parce que
j'aime vraiment l'environnement
c'est en 1979 que la basilique a été
inscrite au patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité et pour continuer à
bénéficier de ce classement
la commune doit être au prix préserver
ce chef-d'oeuvre de l'art roman en
l'espace de quarante ans le sanctuaire a
subi de nombreuses restaurations
on a face à nous la tour saint-antoine
que nous venons de finir de restaurer le
chantier a duré environ une année
et dans quelques temps on va s'attaquer
à la restauration des parties
occidentales de l'édifice
très concrètement la charge que
représente la restauration de ceux de ce
bâtiment et des espaces publics qui lui
sont associés ne peut pas être supporté
par la commune seule donc le fait d'être
inscrit sur la liste du patrimoine
mondial permet à l'état de nous
accompagner beaucoup plus fortement qu
un autre édifice avec sa forte affluence
touristique vézelay souhaite également
aujourd'hui décrocher le label grand
site de france pour faire rayonner
l'ensemble de son territoire
vez est une commune qui accueille un
million de visiteurs aujourd'hui ces
visiteurs ne font que passer
le but de la démarche et de les
fidéliser les démarches d'associations
avec les communes environnantes de
permettre à ce l'ensemble du territoire
d'accueillir ses visiteurs et de
remettre de rester et de permettre à une
économie touristique hôtelière de
restauration de deux chambres d'hôtes et
de gîtes de de vivre et de contribuer
ainsi à la dynamique économique du
territoire
des pèlerins de compostelle aux amoureux
de l'art religieux
vz petite commune du morvan est plus que
jamais un lieu admirer où convergent les
regards de tous les horizons